seventh round pick in the O nine draft
seven quality seasons in the league you
won Dancing with the Stars in season 24
he also has a new book out part one of a
series of four books for kids arcade in
the triple-t token part of the coin slot
chronicle series a new fiction book
series for kids from author Rashad
Jennings good to see you sir pleasure
how's life I mean you got everything
going on right now yeah I got it's a lot
there's a lot happening I'm humble to be
a part of it all I've been having so
much fun since retiring from the league
and I didn't just walk away from then I
fell I actually danced away which opened
up the door for a lot of other things
you didn't dance to victory away from
the NFL as well let's talk about the
games and the matchup of Super Bowl 53
first Rashad Jennings do you feel that
the right teams made the Super Bowl may
I mean I don't know that's a very
stilted question it is still good
question but I think you're getting my
meaning here yeah yes I do because I
never want to get to the point and I
always say I've always said this and I
even put this out as a question to this
as social media do you like to see a
game that is ends in a close game or do
you like to see a blowout I love to see
blowouts because there's no dispute who
won and for me as an athlete you never
want to put it in the hands of anybody
else and so if it ever gets to the point
where we're questioning the referees as
an athlete I've always said well I
shouldn't let it get to that position so
yes the right teams are about to compete
for the Super Bowl no doubt yeah I mean
Brees did say that essentially after the
game that there were a lot of points
that they left out on the field hmm um
and and I always on the show recount the
the line that Rod Woodson Pro Football
Hall of Famer first-ballot Hall of Famer
told me that Chuck Noll would tell him
the Hall of Fame head coach the stills
play better than the rest ref is what he
would tell the Steelers every time
before they went out to play game play
better than the refs ref yeah that said
um we know that mistakes get made as we
saw would you be would you be or do you
think players would be up for having
everything challengeable so you could be
able to challenge hey that should have
been pass interference well I mean yes
some
players would but then the game every
every single call would be challenged I
mean what is this what is this now if
you keep the number the University of
challenge of challenges in the pocket of
a coach the same so you can't challenge
everything it's not every play go got
challengeable you still only have two
challenges and you still need to get
both right to get the third it's just
that everything you could just challenge
everything the issue would be what
happens in the last two minutes with the
NFL or the league or whoever the sky
judge is buzzed into every single play
right that is the issue then the
question is how come we believe the last
two minutes of a game is more pivotal
than the remaining time so all of the
time beforehand equals the last two
minutes so why do we why are we so
currently concerned about the last two
versus the entire game so that's a great
point because in the NBA and the NBA
correct me if I'm wrong Chris Brockman
you are they the the replay system
buzzes in for for whether a ball is out
of bounds and on whom in the last two
minutes of an NBA game or half but not
the rest of it which drives me crazy
they missed that huh posing one when the
rockets and warriors was playing great
and I think the Rockets in the Lakers
this past weekend it was it was insane
no I know that exactly right
so but I think then I think then we're
losing our art of the game and focus and
indie comes down to focus in on the
referee it becomes now that the referee
is the game more so if we continue to
put so much of the the final cost in the
referees hands it's the players it's the
coaches the referees are there to make
sure it's constructed there are gonna be
mistakes made we know that to judge the
person that's making the mistake
constantly I get that to a certain level
but to slow the game down to nitpick
every little detail it loses the art of
the game I mean for getting a sake if we
don't have anything to discuss like now
if everything was perfect the game
almost would be boring
huh yeah I'm not that that's always been
Rashad Jennings here on the show that's
always been a theory thrown out
throughout the years about the old BCS
system and college football before the
BCS system that the argument as to who's
number one or who should be in the
national championship game was always a
positive that at least where it got
controversy to talk about I was never I
want something a system to actually work
and work right right that's what I'd
prefer I prefer something to work right
then then bask in the controversy
because it's something to talk about I
know what you're saying and a lot of
people do believe that I'm just not one
of those people but so you know that
said speaking on behalf of all NFL
players which I'm allowing you to do
focused some pressure guys okay let me
think about it if the league and
competition committee does nothing
players would be fine with that fine
some some will be honestly not to change
the topic but go for it I personally
would be the person beating on a table
to change overtime rules more so than
looking at the refs okay why is that
because in overtime so the first half of
a game you flip the coin somebody gets
the ball yes the second half the other
team gets the ball mhm
so an overtime you flip the coin only
one team gets the ball the opponent
doesn't even have a chance to score so
now we're putting the fate of an entire
game on a coin toss I don't like it I
would say I'd rather allow both teams to
get it once at least regardless of what
the score is and if they both score let
them play until until they get the
quarters over until somebody scores
again the way I so let's get into this a
little bit Rashad Jennings thousand
seven year NFL veteran Dancing with the
Stars champion author of a new series of
books for kids here in the Rich Eisen
show okay I do look at the way that the
AFC Championship game ended
we're Tom Brady got the ball first cuz
he was lucky enough to win a coin toss
5050 went in the Patriots direction and
the presumed most valuable player of the
league was there doing nothing and
allowed to do nothing and walked off the
field with no ability to respond is
similar to a long drawn-out trial having
one lawyer being able to give a closing
statement and that's it the other side
is not allowed to give a closing
statement just the first one is allowed
that's it and the jury has to make its
decision and more often than not we'll
just go with the last thing that they
heard that said what about the idea that
the Chiefs keep my the endzone it's your
job as a defender to keep them out of
the end zone it is it totally is your
job but but this office jobs courts who
so what now check this out though here
they hear me on if you kick a field goal
three points the other team gets the
ball that's allowed to respond because
they tried it they they had a problem
with nobody else being able to respond
when it was just a field goal that could
win it right right so hear hear me out
you can score there's like ours only a
field goal they can score more points
right hmm well it's just seven they can
go for a two-point conversion and go up
by eight and win the reason why you kick
a field goal well let's give them an
opportunity see if they're gonna score
well how about you score let's give them
an opportunity to go for a two-point
conversion it went either way I don't
like a game ending off of a coin toss
and not allowing the opponent to have
that on the coin toss you know what I'm
saying like the Saints got the ball and
this is what the Rams fans are saying
about how unfair it is to say that they
don't have are they're not deserving to
go to the Super Bowl because you have no
idea if that penalty was in fact called
as it should have been you have no idea
if there was gonna be some sort of Romo
bobble on the snap for the field goal
that they wouldn't have gotten one off
and they would have gone to overtime
anyway I mean we can't sit here and say
that everything would have gone a
hunky-dory certainly when we saw a Bears
team get eliminated because the ball hit
the upright and cross
it's bizarre things happen okay so not
only that but Saints got the toss go
that way they got the ball in the hands
of the goat Drew Brees in a building
where he'd never lost a playoff game
before right and they made a defensive
play and that off and then picked it off
and won in an ml that makes sense
because they see the opponent's stops
you but on the on the ladder when you
have on the other game the Patriots
playing against the Kansas City Chiefs
yes it's pretty much gonna come down to
whoever won that coin toss really I mean
I don't know so check this out if the
coin toss in Kansas City got it yes
right and they went and scored I would
still say sure Brady needs to touch it
let them I turn to you mr. defense
should stop I mean would you be sitting
seemingly a conversation because the
Patriots won the game and no one likes
that totally disagree because III don't
care less you can say that but the
numbers don't even back that up to 44
percent of the time when the road team
wins the coin toss they win the game I'm
not looking at percentage I what I'm
talking about
is the fairness for both teams to
actually perform because they explained
to me why four quarters to perform well
no now they have a fifth one too because
of overtime it was a tie which I don't
even agree with flour and ties and games
either I understand the tie but to where
we are at right now are you okay with
fatigue in overtime kicks a field goal
ooh are you okay with the opponent yeah
because they essentially stop them
that's a stop that's a score a field
goal is a stop in overtime when the rule
is touchdown wins the game you stopped
them by allowing them to Kadesh ball and
giving your offense a chance to respond
so okay so you're up seven so if you
score a touchdown you're upset it was
six essentially yes right to kick the
extra point do you have to kick the
extra point in overtime
no cuz the game's over but one if but
what if they block it
what if they block that extra point what
if the opponent goes down the score and
kicks it and wins if you with the field
a few four
you know so here I think what you're
saying is this and I agree I cuz I look
at everything from the from the fan
point of view I want to see Patrick
mahomes counter at the more split I all
you know I understand it is it is a it
is in it should be a punitive response
if you give up a touchdown and overtime
but I still want to see a response you
should still be allowed to put the chief
should still be allowed to run out there
or if you said that the situation
reversed Brady should still be allowed
to run out there and go for a touchdown
yes which would make for some fourth and
eighth attempts from somebody's own 14
exhilarating yeah and if they complete
it and get down the field and then
they've got four cracks from inside the
ten would be exhilarating and then the
opportunity of another coach saying you
know what I want to end it right here
I've got a nine year contract left I'm
not gonna get fired by my coach I'm not
gonna be on a griddle
even if my fan base goes crazy I'm gonna
go out there and go for two and try and
win it or you send your field goal your
extra point team out there and the
kicker misses it and what's the worse
that can happen he winds up on The Today
Show
yeah saying about how he deserves the
most honorific yes and it comes to
fourth down your punting you're giving
the team an extra down to respond that's
the issue too as you these the team yeah
I well that's part of the game now like
what are you saying if you win the toss
and you go down the field
mmm-hmm it really is still in certain
parts of the field a three down
proposition you're gonna punt it if it's
fourth and eight from your own fourteen
yes however if you know you have to
score a touchdown damn the torpedoes you
it's a four down situation for the team
that's been able to respond so what
Bella check go ahead and kick the ball
off and overtime under these new rules
he's done it before
yeah I mean but there that's how it
always is if you're losing and in its
way you water you're always rephase game
and your face gave up the worst possible
scenario
it gave up a touchdown well this is
something again we didn't I didn't bring
up with Stephen Jones cuz instead I
talked about the replay system and then
the fumbling through the end zone which
drives me absolutely insane ever getting
up before I let you go in the few
minutes we have remaining because we
could go we could go in this
cycle throughout the rest of the day I
do want to talk about your book here
arcade and the triple token the coin
slot chronicles you've written four of
these is just the first one yes it's the
first of four and like I said man I was
a very quiz ative kid and asked a lot of
questions and what's what's unique about
this kid is he's funny I'm he's quirky
he's always right the Pratt the the
protagonist named arcade yes okay he's
always right and what I mean buddy he's
always right and people will come to
appreciate this about him you know if
you example he's taking a test and a
question is how many sides to a stop
sign
his options are 12 10 8 and 7 mm-hmm he
puts 10 8 sides in the front of bat he's
right
mm-hmm but he's wrong to the test and so
throughout the book he's frustrated all
the time because he's and people
understand this kid is actually right I
understand his mind but he's always
thrown under the bus he's questioned my
authority he wants to put tests on him
and he gets this called golden token it
takes him in an alternative world to
actually learn why society is looking at
him the way it does it teaches him how
to handle with bullying teachers how to
handle with thoughts of suicide it
teaches him how to handle success and
inside of this slot in an alternative
world it kind of takes him on journeys
he gets the ghost visitor I for salary
he gets to go back in history that
Tolkien takes him anywhere he wants in
the world to learn that's when he comes
back a different person so it teaches
kids to to be patient to not beat
yourself up and accept who you are truly
because if you're judged you know if you
judge a tree you know or you judge a
fish by how well it climbs a tree it's
gonna think it's stupid hmm
so this book allows kids to be judged in
the right way I've got a 10 year old 8
year old and putting it right in their
hands for you should I go home today
this is awesome this is great and you
can get it where all books are sold all
books are sold and you can go to the
website RK livingstone dot-com to find
out more information I will be doing a
book tour and visiting and as many
schools as possible good for you Rashad
Jennings that's awesome and you look
like you're in great shape and I know
this not only cuz you're dumb
sitting here and this is why I'm
bringing this up when you go to
unbreakable performance Jay Glazer is
Jim hmm who's the hardest-working guy
that you've seen in well I listen yeah
rich me and they're getting it in hey
I'm gonna try to record him on his
sneaker and post a movie and there's
sweating his tail off so you got that
face on my face don't don't talk to me
right now I'm time don't talk to me I'm
tired don't talk to me I'm tired but I'm
but I'm a reminding cuz I'm rich only
known to me his name fits him so it
works I don't even know that I have a
fantasy name next year rich Jim fish I'm
getting ready for my run here I'm
focused on the prize here I want to beat
one of the guys the combine this year I
want to go in there and actually have
Deon look at me after my run and go you
know what humble host good job like it's
I want that my wife I want brockman to
be proud of me as opposed to calling me
uphill towards going oh my god again
that's what I want so I'm focused in the
gym am i giving off the vibe don't talk
to me nice it's so what happens when a
person endures a lot of is under a lot
of stress intentioned blood runs
everywhere right and when blood is
running as kind of like do some things
and so you have this look Adam don't
talk to me right now oh my gosh I
honestly I do my work I said I think I'm
a part of it a it's a wonderful
community that glazed and everybody is
built in there ya know it is par the
reason why you go there and absolutely
it's a family as a family but you work
out like you planned over time there you
go response I want to score and what no
respond okay I can't but when I go in
there today like the coin slot
chronicles all four of them when they
come out arcade and the triple-t token
is first up I mean unless there's
teachers there's a teacher's guide to
this book and that's a part of you know
I always thought it'd be cool in school
if the author could come in and I could
talk to them of course about the
literature I fell out with grasps a
better understanding so I am offering
school visits if this is inside your
school at Rashad Jennings on Twitter and
Instagram is another way to contact for
shot also through his foundation that
which is Rashad Jennings foundation.com
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience